[Música]
bienvenidos a esta cita cultural
france24 que hoy venera el ingenio
artístico de angy machista hace ya 150
años que nació el pintor pero también
dibujante grabador y escultor cuya firma
fuera la de color y forma sobre todo
desde 1904 cuando empieza a hacer
vibrante el color y a cumplir con su fe
de que un artista es en la medida que
logra introducir nuevos signos en el
lenguaje por eso no se constriñó a un
estilo en sus viajes medio de los
marroquíes y los moriscos y no se quedó
solo en lo visual machis fue de lo
plástico a la palabra y esa relación de
escrituras les sirve de homenaje al
pompidou de parís que hasta febrero de
2021 exhibirá su vida como si fuesen
nueve capítulos de una novela estas
cinco décadas de evolución son narradas
por 230 obras y 70 archivos otros
autores como el poeta malagueño y por
supuesto el propio en jim hachís
bajo el cielo de parís and climate east
demuestra su inabarcable talento con
esculturas sus primeros lienzos que
datan del final del siglo 19 con escenas
oscuras y naturalezas muertas cuadros
salvajes pintados en el 20
revolucionando el trato del color y la
forma hasta sus famosos papeles cortados
que coronaron su vida he aquí el
autorretrato del pintor que creció en
boán en una tienda de droguería y
semillas de frágil salud recurrente
tenía 20 años cuando su madre le regaló
un set de pinturas en el hospital tal
fue la revelación que se convirtió en el
maestro de los lienzos coloridos y el
gran experimentado de técnicas plásticas
[Música]
tiene matices cuyo credo era la
sinceridad fue un artista incansable que
vivió sin atarse del divisionismo el
fauvismo y el cubismo su mano rápida y
segura buscaba y decidía en un solo
trazo alcanzando el color más
imaginativo de creación de los de
y
estos cuadros de toque infantil y jovial
son en realidad fruto de un largo
trabajo de madurez un ejemplo icónico la
blusa rumana
obtener 67 matices para que en la
pintura fue su paraíso murió en niza en
1954 considerando esta magnolia la más
bella de sus creaciones
nos hemos colado en el pompidou pero la
muestra también es virtual opción que ya
no quieren ni soportan teatros como el
gran liceo catalán protagonista de la
protesta más creativa del 2020 puede que
haya abierto pérez alto por la cultura y
contra los drásticos aforos reducidos
que en su caso dirigen a la ruina su
traviata de verdi y como lo hizo con una
maratónica acción musical que contó con
invitados que simbolizaron el tope
permitido y vieron el montaje de la
ópera además usando el silencio de la
obra de john cage pusieron en valor a la
música que luego durante toda la noche
brotó del pianista al luxemburgués
francesco tristán o 12 horas de
reivindicación a partir de las becas yo
de erik satie pieza que indica la
humillación que vivió un músico cuando
en 1852 una pintora le dejó por un
banquero imaginen repetir sus 152 notas
840 veces
el cine por su parte ya apunta a los
óscar el baile ying de netflix es un
ejemplo aunque esta elegía rural no saca
jugo a sus matices y la crítica la ha
tumbado cuestionando incluso si amy
adams y glenn close ameritan premio ella
salva en el drama basado en las memorias
de yale y vans célebre tras la victoria
de donald trump por tratar la clase
trabajadora y una familia con violencia
y drogadicción que evoca a los olvidados
de américa juzguen si ron howard supera
el reto o cae en una historia de
superación hollywoodense sin
complicaciones
[Música]
en el frank de amazon prime son menos
las dudas al árbol de 'american beauty'
está detrás de un road trip entrañable
que tiene sus sutilezas y su
tragicomedia si la sobrina del tío frank
descubre que éste es gay y que al no
encajar en la familia huyó a nueva york
para ser profesor pero una pérdida los
cambiará al tener que regresar a su
pueblo sureño igual que bolt se fue de
la gran manzana hasta el georgia a
contarle a su madre su homosexualidad
[Música]
como despedida miramos al futuro porque
como la leyenda que es y siempre será
allí está diego armando maradona de
hecho este 2021 amazon prime le rendirá
homenaje con una serie
biografía autorizada por el astro que ha
sido inspiración de múltiples
expresiones culturales emir kusturica y
asif kapadia le dedicaron dos de los
documentales más reconocidos sobre su
vida mientras que hace poco netflix
recreó su penúltima dirección técnica en
sinaloa en méxico pero las
representaciones más emblemáticas son
musicales como la mano de dios' de
rodrigo manu chau o andrés calamaro a
través de él de este último hoy
recordamos que 2020 se despidió del gran
maradona muchísimas gracias y cuídense
[Música]
el pueblo y fortune